Speaker 1: The Department of Justice has announced
a special counsel to investigate and potentially
bring criminal charges against failed former
President Donald Trump. Indictment seems imminent,
according even to many right wing legal scholars.
Even Trump's lawyers reportedly are preparing
for an indictment. Trump is losing his mind
over this. And we'll get to that in a moment.
What is it that is going to take place here?
Well, CNN reporting DOJ announces special
counsel for Trump related Mar a Lago and January
six Criminal Investigations. Multiple criminal
investigations. At this time, Merrick Garland,
the attorney general, appointed a special
counsel to oversee these investigations. Both
investigations implicate the conduct of Trump,
who is now a presidential candidate, Garland said.
Based on recent developments, including Trump's
announcement that he's a candidate for president
and the sitting president stated intention to be
a candidate as well. I have concluded it is
in the public interest to appoint a special
counsel that special counsel is going to be a guy
named Jack Smith. Jack Smith is the former chief
prosecutor for the special court in The Hague,
where he investigated war crimes in Kosovo. Smith,
quote, has built the reputation as an impartial
and determined prosecutor. That is absolutely
correct. And these right wingers and Trumpists
have wasted no time in going right into the
character assassination that we should expect
about Jack Smith. I don't even want to devote time
to that right now. If it becomes a bigger part of
the story, and maybe it will, because all these
people have is character assassination, maybe
we will talk a little bit more about Jack Smith.
Jack Smith's appointment and his selection is
completely uncontroversial. It is just a normal,
uncontroversial prosecutor. Okay, so what is
it that is going to happen here? Continued CNN
article. According to multiple sources, both
the Mar-A-Lago investigation and the January
6th investigation around Trump are aiming to
gather more information and bring witnesses into
a federal grand jury in the coming weeks. This
is a really big deal. I know that many of you
like me have become desensitized to this because
everything about this failed former presidency has
been so unusual and so out of what is typical.
But this is really not normal. We grand juries
for multiple potential crimes committed by
a former president who lost after one term,
tried to stay in office despite losing and is now
running again, potentially because he thinks it
will help him avoid these investigations,
which Merrick Garland says it will not.
Some of the witnesses being pursued in this round
had not spoken to the investigators in cases
before. Many in Trump's orbit believed in hope
the investigation was slowed or halted because
they hadn't heard from the Justice Department for
weeks. Well, that isn't going to go on. So there's
two views of this decision. Now, if we zoom out
officially, the decision is clear. Merrick Garland
was hired by Joe Biden. Joe Biden has stated his
intention to run for reelection. The target of
this investigation is Donald Trump. Donald Trump
has now said he's running for not reelection, but
for another election. And as a result, Garland's
boss could potentially face off against the guy
he's investigating in order to remove himself
from possible allegations of political bias. Here,
Merrick Garland has done the obvious thing, which
is to appoint a special counsel to say, You come
in and figure this all out. We won't get involved
in the charging decisions. Now, there's two views
on this one view, and I heard it from a couple of
you, is that Merrick Garland is a coward. Merrick
Garland is afraid to actually do the thing that
many prosecutors seem to be afraid to do, which is
to charge Donald Trump. We saw this in New York.
We saw the cells elsewhere. They are afraid to be
the first to say, all right, you know what? The
evidence is there. The standards have been met.
I'm going to be the first to charge a
former president. That's one perspective.
And there is no doubt that there are many
prosecutors extraordinarily hesitant and
you could argue, scared to charge
a former president. I concede that
the second view is that Garland is smart to
distance himself from this ultimate decision,
that it's predictable that because Trump announced
this campaign, you really just can't I mean,
think of the counter counter point to this,
which would be Trump says, I'm now a candidate.
He's campaigning and Joe Biden's attorney general
is investigating Trump. Fox News wouldn't let that
fly as much as they seem to be distancing from
Trump right wing media. Republicans wouldn't let
that fly. So whether or not you think Garland is
a coward and he may be I mean, I'm not weighing
in on that. It's neither here nor there. I don't
think Garland had any choice. He can't actively be
in an administration that could be running
against Trump and investigating Trump. It
just doesn't look good. Now, when you zoom
out a little further, there are a number of
legal experts who have looked at this and said,
this is what's going on. This is speculation,
but there's a lot of consensus behind it.
Garland probably realizes at this point.
The evidence against Trump is so strong, he's
going to end up getting charged one way or
another, either for the stolen documents or for
something related to January 6th. And Garland
needs to be able to, as quickly as possible,
separate himself from the line prosecutors and the
final steps of that investigation. And I believe
that it is accurate that he should be doing that.
But many are also seeing this and saying this also
suggests the indictment is imminent. Obviously,
if that indictment comes, we will have it for you.
Let's now look at Donald Trump's reaction to this.